Now that we've motivated the vision, let's see how
we can implement the vision. In order to implement
this vision, the operating system should provide quality of
service APIs to the application. And these quality of service
APIs could be things like, oh, this particular network
flow that I'm creating has certain real time constraints, because
it has video data and so on and so
forth. And those are the hints that the operating system
is going to use, in terms of synthesizing
code that corresponds to the API that the
operating system is providing you, to give hints
to the network. So, the code that the
operating system is going to synthesize is essentially
taking the quality of service constraints, and putting
them as executable code that can be, then passed it on as part of the packet.
So in other words, the protocol stack of the
operating system has to be enhanced to service these
quality of service requirements, and generally to synthesize the
code that has to be part of the payload.
So the application is not only providing a payload,
but it is giving quality of service constraints. And
the operating system, in addition to the payload, generates
or synthesizes code corresponding to this quality of service instructions.
And this slaps on the IP header for where
this particular message is eventually to be delivered, and
hands it over to the Internet. And in the
Internet, if we assume that the Internet routers are capable
of executing this specialized code, then depending on the
nature of what is being requested, a particular order may
say, oh this particular packet I have to send
it to multiple destinations, so let me send this down
this link, down this link, and similarly when it
comes over here, this router may say, oh, this packet
has to go to multiple destinations. And so on and
that we can see that intelligent routing decisions can be
taken in the network. That's out of the road
map of how we can take this vision and try
to implement it. But the problem with carrying out the
vision, in terms of this implementation that I just sketched,
is that changing the operating system is non-trivilous,
especially the protocol stackers, they have already mentioned TCP
IP has several hundred thousand lines of code, so
it is non trivial to change the protocol stack
of every node in the entire universe. To handle
active networks. And also, the second part of the
challenge is that the network routers are not open.
So, in other words, we cannot expect that every
router on the Internet is capable of processing the code that
I'm going on slap on to this payload and be able
to make intelligent routing decisions. So there is a impedance mismatch
between the vision and the implementation that I've sketched right here.